yeah one of the things that I found the
speed listening really helps with is uh
just reducing the cost of a book
so I was at this philanthropy retreat
thing over the weekend where people were
talking about Ai and biosecurity and
pandemic prevention and like how do we
avert nuclear war and I just found
myself being like I have no idea what
anyone's talking about here and so in
conversations with people I was like
what's like the one or two books you'd
recommend to kind of get up to speed on
what the what what the hell's going on
with nuclear for example and this Chapel
I spoke to who works in policy was like
you know this is really good book called
The Bomb which came out recently that
charts the history of nuclear war from
the 1960s onwards
you should try that out and I was like
all right cool and immediately just
opened up Amazon on my phone bought it
on Audible I saw it was a 12 hour read I
was like cool I can get through this in
about three hours yeah something like
that and I started listening to it on
the drive home and already like you know
two hours two or so hours into it like
listening at about about 2.5 x speed
because there was a lot of names and
stuff and I'm not overly familiar with
how the US government works so it's like
you know let's slow it down a bit I now
feel like oh my God like I now have so
much context on the nuclear thing which
is I I had zero on like other than
studying the Cuban Missile Crisis in
like history when I was 15. beyond that
I knew nothing about any of this and
it's like oh it turns out there's all
this like drama between the Air Force
and the Navy and the Army and the
Marines all the stuff around nuclear
like stuff with the Kremlin the hotline
there's some really cool [__] and if
that if that had been recommended to me
as a book and I would have seen how
dense it is just like I'm never gonna I
wouldn't have read Brandon Sanderson
because I would have seen how big the
freaking way of Kings is but as an
audiobook as an audiobooker like a speed
multiple
it only costs me about three hours of
time where I'm driving or at the gym to
be able to actually ingest a lot of
information about nuclear and maybe I
can't recite the names of like oh in
1963 this was the person who was the
head of the Department of State or
whatever but I don't really need to
because what I care about is getting the
gist and a general understanding of the
topic yep the story and the plot plus
it's asynchronous time right to read a
book you need to not drive not work out
not cook you're sitting at a desk you
know even reading while you're on the
train or in an Uber is difficult but if
I'm listening you know I finish my zoom
call like here's my how my day goes
right I wake up in the morning airpods
go in I start listening I brush my teeth
I'm listening I'm cooking breakfast I'm
listening I take them out when I'm
eating breakfast with my teammates and
then if I have five minutes between a
zoom call and where I'm in I'll listen
and then I finished the zoom call I'm
gonna head over here cool I start
listening I get in the Uber I like might
pick up a phone call or two the second
the phone call ends I go back to
listening my airpods just don't leave my
ears and then I only stop listening I
texted you hey I'm downstairs but I can
do things and listen at the same time
and when you show up downstairs I stop
listening and so all that dead time in
the day typically is like three to four
hours I'm listening to a book but I'm
listening at 3x speed
nice lovely life
um now
that thing that you just said I imagine
there are some people listening to this
thinking oh my [__] God that sounds
incredible and just as many probably
like the worst thing in the world this
guy's a psychopath like
um I wonder like I mean most people do
the same thing but with music
right so let's take Hamilton for example
um I eat biographies for breakfast I'm
obsessed right like I literally wrote a
rap album about the life of Arnold
Schwarzenegger after I listened to
Hamilton for the first time
um Hamilton the musical it's about two
hours 40 minutes long it is the best
biography of Hamilton in my opinion
right it's dramaticized but like you
can't take away from the beat and lyrics
and everything else when you listen to
music it's exactly like listening to a
book especially if you pay attention to
the lyrics by the way one really cool
thing is if you start listening to a lot
of audiobooks you will notice and
remember all the lyrics from all the
songs you listen to most people who I am
friends with
um you know they listen to the beat or
the melody and they don't necessarily
recall or understand the lyrics they
need to look at the lyrics on their
phone to really and take them for me
like both happen because I've trained
that part of my brain
but if you already do this for music why
do you do it with music because it
enriches your life It Makes You Happy
Well Brandon sanderson's uh you know the
way of Kings enriches my life I'm sorry
even more than music and so again it
doesn't matter if it's fantasy or
fiction or philosophy or sci-fi I listen
because it makes me happy it's it's
beautiful it's enjoyable I'm living
inside this world and the joy that you
get from a book if you've read a book is
so much deeper than the Joe you get from
watching a movie or watching a TV series
and so I don't watch TV I don't watch
movies I just consume books but I do it
with my ears
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye